Good morning, John
I kinda feel like that we've been really fancy on vlogbrothers lately
(We've) Got music video, big epic collab video, travel vlogs, tax plans, brazil video...
... you did a review of Monopoly
Let's simplify for a while
I'm just going to tell a story
A couple of years ago I was in the Bay area
I landed and I was going to a hotel that was a while away
so I got in a taxi and it took me to the hotel
The taxi driver was super nice
He asked me where I was from, we talked about Montana
He asked me why I was there, we talked about why i was there
... which is that I was doing a thing for the launch of Randell Munroe's book "What If"...
... which is a fantastic book
I even read to him a little bit from the book...
... because I just think "What If" is such a great thing to share with people.
But, like a paragraph in, the taxi driver
.. he's like "Oh No!"
So then I'm also like "Oh what oh what happened?!"
... and he tells me that the cable that connects the meter to the transmission ...
has fallen out, meaning it hadn't recorded the first part of our journey
and if he plugged it in now then he'd only get paid for half.
But he said he'd be fine because he does this trip a lot
He knows how much it costs
So he'll just charge me that
we get to the hotel and he tells me $120
And I say, "Okay"
And then I go to bed, and I get up in the morning
I do the event. It's great. And then..
I get another taxi, from that same hotel, to the airport
and its $65.
And then I realized
Like it didn't even occur to me!
But yeah
And of course, immediately I'm like
... that guy was only nice to me, because he wanted to...
...know where I was from
And he trying to make it seem like
... there is no way this could be the kind of guy
... that would take advantage of me
He's so nice
I think about all the ways
in which I could have protected myself
from that, like so many..
common sense little things that I could have done
to prevent myself from getting taken advantage of in that way.
Mostly just being ashamed that I was such like a country bumpkin rube.
That I was this guys mark, I was the patsy.
And it made me feel like an idiot for trusting someone
and not being more skeptical.
This one little example of the world like not always being totally on my side
And I start rethinking my entire, like
policy of being intentionally over-trusting.
Which is a thing that actually think about.
I want to be that.
So this guy definitely stole like 50-60 bucks from me
but that, by far, was not the greatest, like,
negative impact that this experience had on me.
Suddenly I'm thinking, like, how do I avoid getting taken advantage of again?
All the space in my brain that my new like, theft protection algorithms are going to take up
And just generally building a wall between me
and the world that's gonna decrease my enjoyment of the world.
And this, from me, a guy who's pretty much got the whole world on his side
I'm a straight white dude with money
Just one little betrayal and I'm rethinking
the way I think about all other humans?
Come on!
Maybe every act of trust is a gamble that we choose to make.
But I think the feeling of being taken advantage of
is way less pleasant than the feeling of having your
trust be justified and having the good, desired outcome happen.
On the scale of violations of trust, of  course,
a taxi driver stealing your money and you not being smart enough to, like, realize it's happening
is reeaally far down the scale.
I don't want to say this was like a huge, terrible thing that happened to me.
I'm just surprised the impact it had on me
and I feel like if I let that change the way I think about the world
that's not bad for the scammer, or the thief,
that's bad for me.
But if that guy is rationalizing his theft -
or if anybody is rationalizing them taking advantage of other people
by saying, like, "yeah that person can afford to have that stuff taken from them (whatever that is)."
Maybe, maybe that's the case
Maybe I can afford to have $60 stolen from me.
But I don't think our society can afford to be constantly looking over its shoulder.
We have to be able to trust each other
or society falls apart.
That to me is the true, untold, unrecognized cost
of being the kind of person who takes advantage of other people's trust.
That thing, not the theft, is what ends up making the world a significantly worse place.
And it makes me really angry.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Hello, there, end screen.
If you're interested in being a part of a street team for my upcoming tour
(dates in the description)
there's a link the the description to a form that you can fill out.
It would be great if you wanted to help us out.